- I just assume everything from Australia,
can kill me.
(didgeridoo music)
- I feel like if I was
growing up in Australia,
I wouldn't make it.
- Snakes sneaking in the house,
spiders sneaking in the house.
- Terrifying, dangerous, creepy.
(upbeat band music)
- Death.
- Yes.
- I'm dead, I'm dead looking at it.
- Is that a horn that he stabs you with.
- The eyes have an agenda here.
- All that crap that's on his beak,
is like human flesh.
- It could probably beak you to death.
- Probably like a head butt
kind of thing, like a ram.
- This things gonna fucking kill you.
- Yeah.
(upbeat band music)
- Whoa what is that?
- This is an animal?
- It seems pretty colorful,
and I know for a fact that
the more colorful an animal,
the more venomous it is.
- Yeah.
- You can see a face in it, and it's like.
- It could probably
destroy your entire life.
- I'm into it but it's
definitely going to kill you.
- It's definitely poisonous
and I think it can kill you.
(upbeat band music)
- Ohhhhh.
- Just yes, like spiders can
kill, all spiders can kill you.
- I'm not going to lie,
my butt hole clenched,
when I saw that spider.
- Doesn't look like an innocent spider.
- It maybe will dig a hole in
my face and plant it's babies.
- I feel like it's not
actually a poisonous spider,
it's just like a very big ass spider.
- I'm gonna go with no, it
looks pretty harmless enough.
(upbeat band music)
- And a tiny angry mouth.
- There's something kind of
charming about this snake.
- It's like friendly house snake.
- I feel like it would hurt,
but I don't think it would kill you.
- I don't think it will kill me.
- I don't know, I like
the looks of this guy,
I feel like he would kill me
though, if he had the chance.
(upbeat band music)
- Oh my god.
He would kill me.
- I don't trust him.
I really honestly don't trust him at all.
- Like I wouldn't want to
run this guy in a dark alley.
- Just imagine if one of
these guys killed you.
That would suck.
You'd be like what the fuck?
- How would this thing kill you?
- Maybe it like strangles
you, with it's tiny fingers.
- I feel like if you run into a nice one,
maybe it won't kill you.
- If my death comes from
this adorable faced creature,
then so be it.
- It's one way to go.
- I accept.
(upbeat band music)
- I still really want to go to Australia.
- Definitely not going in the water, ever.
Like I'll walk on the beach,
I'll check out the cute people.
- Cause I'm probably not going to go,
parading around the outback.
- This is good training,
cause now we know, like ok,
which ones to look out for,
which ones are cool.
- You gotta respect those murder animals.
- Yeah, that's all they're asking for.
Just a little respect.
- Just a little bit.
(upbeat band music)
- Thanks a lot for the nightmares.
- Australia.